today's question is do I think movies
can be genuinely good because of their
badness do I think movies can be yeah I
copied this question so I was asked this
question and I want to answer it but I
don't entirely know how uh because the
types of badness that movies can be are
so varied and indeed within certain you
know spheres within certain genres
within subgenres the things that make a
movie good or or rather the things that
make a movie desirable change and so you
could argue within you know within a
schlocky genre uh within say you know
giant robot anime the things that make a
giant robot anime appealing are not
necessarily the best storytelling
mechanisms but they're appealing to a
very specific language and so internally
they're just they're the way that things
are done they're the way that you
communicate effectively within that
genre they're the things that the
audience expects and anticipates so
something like Pacific Rim is at its
best when it's willing to you know
really indulge itself in in grandiose
like proclamations and giant you know
blood pumping speeches and everyone just
getting super hyped because that's you
know that's its language that's its
dialect that's how it wants to engage
with the audience and that's how the
audience wants to engage with it whether
that makes something objectively good or
bad whether that is you know
theoretically great storytelling is
ultimately you're relevant within that
context now as far as Jurassic world and
specific is concerned it sucks and is
really bad even on a genre level and I
could spend a lot of time pulling apart
Jurassic world and why it is just
terrible
at a genre level at a script level and
at a franchise level and I probably will
as always the best way to reach me for a
question is through ask fm or Twitter
links down below in the description